[Musique]
bonsoir nous sommes le lundi 19
septembre vous regardez le 7 8 le
journal merci de nous retrouver pour
cette nouvelle édition commence tout de
suite avec et le sommaire
mobilisation ce matin devant la mairie
de montigny le bretonneux animateurs et
atsem et d'étangs grève un mouvement
d'ampleur nationale les explications à
suivre et depuis l'attentât de nice cet
été les mesures de sécurité autour des
événements publics ont été renforcés
conséquence de nombreuses manifestations
sont annulées faute d'un dispositif
suffisant le point sur la situation à
saint quentin en yvelines dans cette
édition et enfin nous reviendrons sur
les journées européennes du patrimoine
qui se sont déroulées ce week-end
partout en france mais aussi dans les
yvelines au programme visite de la
préfecture et retour au moyen-age à mort
par
les mouvements de grogne générale c'est
celui des atsem et des animateurs ils
étaient en grève ce matin devant l'hôtel
de ville de montigny la brute le
bretonneux et un peu partout en france
reçus par les membres de la mairie ils
ont fait part de leurs revendications
notamment l'augmentation du nombre
d'animateurs et la revalorisation des
salaires sur les 120 animateurs de la
ville 74 étaient présents leur priorité
est d'établir un dialogue avec la mairie
et de prévoir un échéancier des
prochaines réunions et prise de décision
dix sept écoles primaires et 17 écoles
maternelles sont concernés je vous
propose d'écouter jean philippe lecomte
et animateur à montigny le bretonneux
le métier d'animateur a énormément
évolué depuis quelques années notamment
avec la réforme des rythmes scolaires
tout c'est
tous ces changements entraîné pas mal de
modifications au niveau du travail et
notamment une dégradation au niveau de
l'encadrement des enfants et donc c'est
l'une des premières choses que nous on
veut des lancers et je vous disais en
titre vous le savez suite aux attentats
à l'attentât de nice qui s'est déroulée
le 14 juillet dernier de nombreux
rassemblements et manifestations
publiques ont été supprimés vide
greniers pour ce sportives et même
braderie sont concernés c'est le cas
aussi dans les yvelines où entre autres
la 44e édition de la grande braderie de
huy a été annulé alors qu'en est-il à
saint quentin en yvelines c'est ce que
nous avons voulu savoir regardez
pas de foire à la brocante cette année à
guyancourt l'événement devait se
dérouler ce dimanche 18 septembre place
du marché il a été annulé en amont pour
des raisons de sécurité et de budget
même sort pour le vide greniers de la
mjc aux clayes-sous-bois prévu
initialement le dimanche 2 octobre il
n'aura pas lieu en raison des
difficultés à sécuriser l'ensemble du
périmètre de cette brocante à voisins le
bretonneux aucun événement supprimés
mais la décision n'appartient pas
seulement aux communes elles doivent
suivre des directives de la préfecture
on est en train de prendre chaque
événement à venir déjà jusqu'au mois de
décembre pour vérifier lesquelles
maintien et peut-être si on a supprimé
la suppression des pans de la
sécurisation que nous sommes en mesure
d'apporter et la préfecture nous demande
de remplir un dossier à chaque
manifestation avec le plan vigipirate
les mesures de sécurité ont été augmenté
par rapport aux éditions précédentes
la vigilance doit redoubler notamment
sur les grands rassemblements on a
renforcé les mesures de sécurité
jusque là on essaie de tout garder
parce que en accord avec la police on
les fait dans des lieux fermés pas de
quoi s'alarmer dans les faits la
majorité des communes de saint quentin
en yvelines n'a pas été impactée pour
l'instant d'autres communes qui
ressentent leur événement dans des
espaces fermés
voilà mais tout cela ça concerne que 10
20 % des communes la grande majorité des
communes n'ont pas changé leurs
événements des décisions au cas par cas
qui ne devrait pas trop venir perturber
le calendrier événementiel du territoire
aujourd'hui il n'y a pas d'événements
organisés par l'agglomération qui était
adulé et d'ailleurs nous en train de
travailler avec les services de la
préfecture pour l'organisation des
championnats d'europe de cyclisme sur
piste et cette compétition aura bien
lieu à saint quentin en yvelines soleil
territoire de comptines et d'autres
manifestations sont à l'étude notamment
les courses de plein air difficile à
sécuriser la 16e édition de la route des
quatre châteaux en vallée de chevreuse
en novembre est d'ores et déjà annulé
pour des raisons de sécurité
et revenons sur cet incident qui a lieu
samedi après-midi à lévis un nom un
toboggan gonflable s'est renversé lors
de la fête communale entraînant cinq
enfants a dans sa chute cinq d'entre eux
des enfants dans sa chute par dont cinq
d'entre eux ont été transportés à
l'hôpital ils sont sortis aujourd'hui
est hors de danger le propriétaire de la
structure lui a été remis en liberté
dimanche après une nuit de garde à vue
sion et nouvelle étape pour le chantier
de la rd 30 à plaisir et l'encours un
projet de grande ampleur pour le
département il a connu cet été et depuis
la rentrée de nouvelles avancées la fin
des travaux et donc des difficultés pour
les automobilistes sont prévus pour
l'été prochain les précisions de nicolas
kirillovitch et mélanie poker
objectif améliorer la circulation sur
l'un des axes les plus bouchée du
département le chantier de la rd 30 est
entrée dans une nouvelle phase et
notamment sur le secteur 1 celui des
gâtines la plupart des travaux sont
désormais terminées les derniers
aménagements les plus compliquées ont
débuté durant l'été mise en service
prévue début 2010 est ce secteur avant
était un secteur fortement encombré
la rd 30
il y avait un flux important de gens qui
ce qu'on appelle traversant qui a parce
qu'ils ne font que passer par la rd30
rencontrés assurent trois endroits le
flux locale donc ça années d'énormes
compris que des bouchons importants les
travaux avancent également sur les
secteurs 2 et 3 le futur rond-point du
petit saint cloud située au nord du
chantier sera ainsi mise en service
progressivement à partir de la fin de
l'année à terme l'objectif c'est de
séparer les flux de transit avec les
flux locaux pour cela en fait on réalise
une la dénivellation c'est à dire que la
rd30 passera sous le futur giratoire
afin de séparer les deux trafics
les travaux de la rd 30 prévoit
également l'installation de protection
acoustique ou la création d'une voie
verte coût du projet un peu plus de 78
millions d'euros dont 45 à la charge du
département
la consommation locale est à l'honneur
en ile de france du 10 au 25 septembre
l'événement montjoux lequel en
ile-de-france admettons lumière des
agriculteurs des artisans mais aussi des
restaurateurs nous vous proposons de
partir à la découverte de la biscuiterie
rtl est situé au perray en yvelines et
accueille des pâtissiers de père en fils
depuis
1888 depuis deux ans leurs produits ont
obtenu le label saveurs ile-de-france
s'est courue de falun qui vous en dit
plus
chez les longues et la pâtisserie c'est
une affaire familiale depuis quatre
générations le savoir-faire se transmet
de père en fils c'est mon arrière grand
père qui a commencé
en 1888 n'était pâtissier il a ouvert sa
première boutique en 1906 à vincennes et
mon grand-père a continué en 1946 sur
versailles à la prière
et mon père et mon oncle alain et michel
ont repris en
sur versailles et sont venus au père en
yvelines à côté de rambouillet sur un
site plus approprié pour la production
et on est passé de 1946 à milhas tojours
à 200 mille actuellement
deux cent mille gâteau sans colorant ni
ville de palm commercialisée pour la
grande distribution en ile de france
avec une particularité ils sont
labellisés saveurs ile de france donc on
peut on fait travailler effectivement
des partenaires locaux pour une question
éthique
et puis c'est beaucoup plus sain
effectivement que de faire venir des
produits
de loin pour éviter une mas du carbone
dans l'environnement un produit
coqueluche pour cette entreprise
familiale de 19 personnes synonyme
d'enfance et de tradition la madeleine
reste encore le produit phare et surtout
actuellement elle revient
redevient un petit peu tendance et
r est tendance après sinon bien sûr nous
avons des rochers coco nous avons des
financiers amendes qui ré à qui plaît
bien des moelleux chocolat voilà mais la
madeleine reste le produit phare qu'on
produit le plus les matières premières
de ces petites douceurs son local mais
ce n'est pas tout autres critères pour
obtenir le label saveurs ile de france
la fabrique ce fait elle aussi juste
derrière la boutique ouverte du lundi au
vendredi de 14h à 18h
et revenons à présent sur les journées
européennes du patrimoine elles se sont
déroulées ce week-end dans le
département les événements que visiter
entre autres la préfecture de versailles
une foule de curieux a pu découvrir les
pièces de l'hôtel du département et de
la préfecture ainsi que le bureau du
préfet des yvelines serge morvan écoutez
les il était au micro de michael et demi
d'euros
dont je suis venu parce que j'ai deux
lada par antenne à versailles et on a
profité du fait que ce soit les journées
du patrimoine pour voir un petit peu
toutes les richesses
que l'on découvre dans cette ville on
connaît le château on connaît des allées
on connaît la grande avenue de paris
mais on ne voit pas trop ce qu'il ya
derrière une façade et ses façades dont
cage des merveilles quand même moi je
pense que c'est intéressant de venir
découvrir des lieux qu'on peut voir tous
les jours mais qu'on a pas l'habitude de
visiter comme par exemple la préfecture
on peut découvrir les salons des préfet
secrétariat comment ça se passe c'est
près de 2600 personnes qui on a visité
la préfecture de versailles les visites
théâtralisées mise en scène par éric
bouvron et 12,1 dont nous avons parlé au
domaine de madame elisabeth et à l'hôtel
du département à versailles ont attiré
aussi de nombreux curieux et en tout
c'est plus de 4000 personnes qui ont
visité des sites du département ce
week-end et à maurepas à l'occasion de
ces journées européennes du patrimoine
la ville a décidé de rendre hommage à
l'histoire de notre territoire pour
l'occasion un village du moyen âge a été
reconstituée au pied du donjon de la
ville un voyage end au temps des
chevaliers signés camille lambert et
michael aimait d'euros
[Musique]
12,2 arpt maniement des armes aux
poteries danton plongée au coeur du 15e
siècle dans le cadre des journées
européennes du patrimoine un village
médiéval ait installé au pied du donjon
ne mord pas occasion de découvrir la vie
quotidienne de nos ancêtres
nous avons donc retracer un peu
l'histoire bas de maurepas voyage nous
avons fait un jeu sur les temps du
moyen-âge donc petits et grands peuvent
participer nous avons les arts
plastiques qui vont faire des des épées
des hommes pour les enfants des
activités pour les enfants nous avons
les compteurs du bois joli aussi clients
que font des comptes
en partenariat avec la ville et
l'association mort pas d'hier et
d'aujourd'hui les regrattiers d'histoire
font découvrir leurs spécialités aux
visiteurs par q s'occupe du logis il
explique l'utilité des différents
ustensiles pour la table et son métier
de dégraisseur je parcours les rues de
paris notamment en criant allah
maletache donc en criant vraiment dire
al amal tâches comme ça comprenez donc à
la mauvaise tâche la tâche rebelles
celles qui résistent sur les vêtements
et donc je jette ses dames ou qu'ils
n'arrivent pas à nettoyer leurs loges et
à se défaire des tâches sur leur vêture
combats d'épées dépaysement garanti une
période qui fascine toujours petits et
grands bah on a déjà fait les chapeaux
pour les filles et puis après on va on
va regarder un petit peu tout ce qui a
nous allons tour dans les tentes à
droite à gauche et puis on verra bien là
on a fait un peu dehors et puis c'est
sympathique c'est joli mettez leur
coiffe tout ça
et piquionne
il est fabriqué avec du tissu des très
belles choses du coup c'est c'est
vraiment un joli
retour moyenâgeux temps d'un week-end
les festivités se sont terminées
dimanche
[Applaudissements]
une dernière information avant de
refermer à ce journal françois de
mazières ancien président de la cité de
l'architecturé et du patrimoine et
actuel maire de versailles a publié une
tribune dans le figaro vox à l'occasion
des journées du patrimoine il s'insurge
de la baisse des dotations allouées au
patrimoine français et évoque un
sacrifice du patrimoine et des
rénovations a fait trop tard il demande
à ce que la politique en faveur du
patrimoine soit à nouveau considéré
notamment durant le prochain quinquennat
c'est à présent la fin de cette édition
je vous remercie de nous avoir suivis et
vous donne rendez vous demain pour un
nouveau numéro du journal la bonne
soirée
[Musique]